sont partout ça mais qui mène aux gens
dont on peut plus faire un pas sans
tomber sur lui je te rappelle que c'est
toi qui les a fait venir habiter ici un
attanquant j'étouffe à claude tomber
dans une autre fois shao parce que là je
suis très en retard on m'a dit embauches
a commenté les vous travaillez vous je
suis affreusement retard doit y aller
pour ça réservez votre soirée du 17 juin
qu'est ce qui se passe au 17 juin je
vais jouer jésus
j étais pas
trois bonjour claude je devrais café et
non
dès ce soir commence à ce soin baoulé
faire chaque matin la maison bon on l'a
fait vendredi dernier à baisser tous les
échos qui arrive du rhône heroes partent
quand ils restent floues -les il a dit
pour une durée indéterminée mais ça
c'est pas du tout flou sme mais non mais
ça y est ça d'immigrés il me
sens vraiment mignon non par son mari
mais combien de temps ça fera bientôt 40
ans le 10 juin c'est l'occasion de
réunir toute la famille commence à toute
la famille donc par en nom personnel il
a trop mal vécu le dîner à pékin
je suis en face de votre sympathique
papa
j'ai l'impression que c'est tromper de
chinois
ils suivent
dit pas encore si on a tiré au sort les
chambres et toi maman vous dormez dans
la yourte quoi vachement sympa une
petite orange y aller ou deviennent de
jaffa on voit bien que vous n'avez
jamais goûté celle de constantine shalom
salam aleikum
tous un problème non me suis coupé les
branches éducation sur sa merci à nos
jours mais
je peux goûter l'assaut quitte à l'égard
des dégâts quand même pas pousser
qu'est-ce qu'on a tous fait au bon dieu
claude ne sait rien
comment on dit en france chacun sa merde
[Musique]